En China está ocurriendo actualmente una enorme revolución de las compras.
El comportamiento de compra y también las plataformas tecnológicas,
han evolucionado de manera diferente que en otras partes del mundo.
Por ejemplo, el comercio electrónico en China se está disparando.
Ha estado creciendo al doble de velocidad que en EE.UU.
y gran parte del crecimiento proviene de los dispositivos móviles.
Todos los meses, 500 millones de consumidores
compran a través de teléfonos móviles.
Y para poner eso en contexto,
eso equivale a la población total de Estados Unidos,
Reino Unido y Alemania.
Pero no se trata solo de la escala del comercio electrónico,
es la velocidad de adopción y la agregación de los ecosistemas.
China tardó menos de cinco años en convertirse en un país de comercio móvil,
y eso se debe en gran parte a las dos plataformas tecnológicas,
Alibaba y Tencent.
Poseen el 90 % del comercio electrónico:
casi todo el mercado,
el 85 % de las redes sociales,
el 85 % del pago por Internet.
Y también poseen grandes volúmenes de contenido digital, video,
películas en línea, literatura, información de viaje, juegos.
Cuando esta gran base de compradores móviles
entra en contacto con los ecosistemas agregados,
se producen reacciones químicas.
Hoy China es como un enorme laboratorio
que genera todo tipo de experimentos.
Deberían venir a China,
porque aquí podrán echar un vistazo al futuro.
Una de las tendencias que he visto es la espontaneidad de las compras.
Hace cinco años, en un estudio sobre moda,
hallamos que en promedio,
un consumidor chino compraba cinco a ocho pares de zapatos al año.
Este número se triplicó hasta llegar a unos 25 pares de zapatos al año.
¿Quién necesitaría tantos pares de zapatos?
Y pregunté: "¿Qué razones tienes para comprar?"
Y me enumeraron varias inspiraciones:
blogs, noticias de celebridades, información de moda.
Pero realmente, para muchos de ellos, no había una razón particular para comprar.
Simplemente estaban navegando un sitio desde el móvil
y compraban lo que veían.
Hemos observado el mismo nivel de espontaneidad en todo,
desde la compra de comestibles hasta la compra de productos de seguros.
Pero no es muy difícil de entender si lo pensamos.
Muchos de los consumidores chinos siguen siendo muy nuevos
en sus estilos de vida de clase media o clase media alta,
con un fuerte deseo de comprar todo lo nuevo,
nuevos productos, nuevos servicios.
Y con este ecosistema integrado,
es muy fácil para ellos comprar, un clic tras otro.
Sin embargo, este nuevo comportamiento de compra supone muchos desafíos
para aquellos negocios que antes dominaban.
El dueño de una compañía de moda me dijo que está muy frustrado
porque sus clientes se quejan de que sus productos no son suficientemente nuevos.
Para una compañía de moda, realmente es un mal comentario.
Y ya aumentó la cantidad de productos en cada colección.
No parece funcionar.
Entonces le dije que hay algo más importante que eso.
Tienes que darle a tu consumidor exactamente lo que quiere
cuando todavía lo quieren.
Y él puede aprender algo de los vendedores de ropa en línea en China.
Estas empresas, recogen comentarios reales de los consumidores
desde sitios móviles, desde redes sociales,
y luego sus diseñadores traducen esta información
en ideas de productos,
y luego lo envían a microempresas para producción.
Estas microempresas son realmente clave en este ecosistema general,
porque toman pequeños pedidos,
30 prendas a la vez,
y también pueden hacer piezas parcialmente personalizadas.
El hecho de que todos estos diseños de producción
se hacen localmente
todo el proceso, desde el transporte hasta el producto en estante o en línea
a veces lleva solo de tres a cuatro días.
Eso es súper rápido,
y eso es altamente receptivo a lo que está adentro y de moda en el mercado.
Y eso está dando enormes dolores de cabeza a los minoristas tradicionales
que solo están pensando en unas pocas colecciones al año.
Luego hay una necesidad del consumidor de ultraconveniencia.
Hace un par de meses, estaba de compras con un amigo en Tokio.
Estábamos en la tienda,
y había tres o cuatro personas paradas frente a nosotros
en el mostrador de caja.
Bastante normal, ¿verdad?
Pero ambos dejamos caer nuestra selección
y nos alejamos.
Así de impacientes nos hemos vuelto.
La ultraconveniencia no es solo algo agradable a ofrecer.
Es crucial asegurarse de que su consumidor realmente compre.
Y en China, hemos aprendido
que esa conveniencia es realmente lo que atraerá compras en línea
un comportamiento y un hábito que se adhiere.
A veces es más efectivo que solo un programa de lealtad.
Por ejemplo, Hema.
Es un concepto de tienda minorista desarrollado por Alibaba.
Entregan una canasta completa de productos
unos 4000 productos hasta su puerta
en 30 minutos.
Lo sorprendente es que entregan literalmente todo:
frutas, vegetales, por supuesto.
También entregan peces vivos
y también el cangrejo real vivo de Alaska.
Como mi amigo una vez me dijo,
"Es realmente mi sueño hecho realidad.
Finalmente, puedo impresionar a mi suegra
cuando viene a visitarme para cenar de improviso".
(Risas)
Compañías como Amazon y FreshDirect
también están experimentando en el mismo campo.
El hecho de que Hema sea parte del ecosistema de Alibaba
lo hace más rápido y también un poco más fácil de implementar.
Para un vendedor de comestibles en línea,
es muy difícil, muy costoso,
entregar una canasta completa rápidamente,
pero para Hema se hace con una aplicación móvil,
tiene pago móvil,
y también tiene 20 tiendas físicas en áreas de alta densidad en Shanghái.
Estas tiendas están diseñadas para garantizar la frescura del producto:
en realidad, tienen peceras en la tienda
y también ofrecen ubicaciones que permiten la entrega de alta velocidad.
Sé la pregunta que tienen en mente.
¿Están ganando dinero?
Sí, están ganando dinero.
Están innovando,
y también sorprende que los ingresos de ventas por tienda
son tres a cuatro veces más altos que en la tienda de comestibles tradicional,
y la mitad de los encargos provienen de dispositivos móviles.
Esto es realmente una prueba de que un consumidor,
si obtiene ultraconveniencia, realmente funciona en la compra de comestibles,
cambiará sus comportamientos de compra en línea,
en poco tiempo.
Así que ultraconveniencia y espontaneidad,
y eso no es todo.
La otra tendencia que he visto en China
es una compra social.
Si se piensa en hacer compras sociales en otro lugar del mundo,
es un proceso lineal.
Eliges algo en Facebook,
lo miras y cambias a Amazon
o brand.com para completar el viaje de compras.
Limpio y simple.
Pero en China es una cosa muy diferente.
En promedio un consumidor pasa una hora en comprar su teléfono móvil.
Eso es tres veces más que en EE.UU.
¿De dónde viene la permanencia?
¿Qué están haciendo en realidad en esta pequeña pantalla?
Les llevaré a un viaje de compra móvil
que es como normalmente sería.
23:11, sí, es generalmente cuando compro.
Estaba chateando en una sala de chat de WeChat con mis amigos.
Uno de ellos sacó un paquete de aperitivos
y publicó el enlace del producto en esa sala de chat.
Lo odio, porque normalmente solo hago clic en ese enlace
y luego llego a la página del producto.
Mucha información, muy colorida,
alucinante.
Lo miró y luego un dependiente entró en línea
y me pregunta: "¿Cómo puedo ayudarte esta noche?"
Por supuesto que compré ese paquete de bocadillos.
Lo que es más hermoso es que sé que al día siguiente, alrededor del mediodía,
ese paquete de bocadillo será entregado a mi oficina.
Puedo comerlo y compartirlo con mis colegas
y el costo de la entrega, máximo un dólar.
Justo cuando estaba a punto de abandonar ese sitio de compras,
apareció otra pantalla.
Esta vez es la transmisión de una celebridad
enseñándome a usar un nuevo color de lápiz labial.
Lo miré durante 30 segundos, muy fácil de entender,
y también había un enlace de compras al lado,
hice clic, lo compré en unos segundos.
De regreso a la sala de chat.
El chisme todavía está en marcha.
Otro amigo mío publicó el código QR
de otro paquete de merienda.
Lo presioné, lo compré.
Así que toda la experiencia
es como si estuvieras explorando en un parque de diversiones.
Es caótico, es divertido
y es incluso un poco adictivo.
Esto es lo que sucede cuando tienes este ecosistema integrado.
Las compras están incrustadas en lo social,
y lo social está evolucionando en una experiencia multidimensional.
La integración de los ecosistemas alcanza un nivel completamente nuevo.
Lo mismo ocurre con su dominio en todos los aspectos de nuestra vida.
Y, por supuesto, hay grandes oportunidades comerciales detrás de esto.
Una compañía china de snacks, Three Squirrels,
construyó un negocio de USD 500 millones en solo tres años
invirtiendo de 300 a 500 asistentes de tienda
que están en línea para brindar servicios 24/7.
En el entorno de las redes sociales,
son como tus amigos del vecindario.
Incluso cuando no estás comprando cosas,
ellos estarán felices de solo contarte algunas bromas y hacerte feliz.
En este ecosistema integrado,
las redes sociales realmente pueden redefinir la relación entre marca,
minorista y consumidor.
Estos son solo fragmentos de los cambios masivos
que he visto en China.
En este enorme laboratorio,
muchos experimentos se generan todos los días.
Los ecosistemas están reformando
la distribución de la cadena de suministro, la comercialización,
la innovación de productos, todo.
Los consumidores tienen el poder de decidir lo que quieren comprar,
cuando quieren comprarlo,
cómo quieren comprarlo, cómo quieren ser sociales.
Ahora está de vuelta a los líderes empresariales del mundo
realmente abrir los ojos y ver lo que está sucediendo en China.
Piénsenlo y actúen.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Massimo Portincaso: Angela, lo que compartiste con nosotros
es realmente impresionante y casi increíble,
pero creo que muchos en la audiencia tenían la misma pregunta que yo,
que es:
¿Es este tipo de consumo impulsivo
económica y ambientalmente sostenible a largo plazo?
Y ¿cuál es el precio total a pagar
para una experiencia minorista automatizada y ultraconveniente?
Angela Wang: Sí. Algo que debemos tener en cuenta
es realmente, estamos en el comienzo de una gran transformación.
Entonces, con estas necesidades de intercambio del consumidor,
junto con la evolución del ecosistema,
hay muchas oportunidades y también desafíos.
Así que he visto algunas señales tempranas
de que los ecosistemas están cambiando su enfoque
prestar atención para resolver estos desafíos.
Por ejemplo, prestar más atención a la sostenibilidad
junto con la velocidad,
y también calidad sobre cantidad.
Pero realmente no hay respuestas simples a estas preguntas.
Esa es exactamente la razón por la que estoy aquí para contarle a todos
que necesitamos verlo, estudiarlo y participar en esta evolución.
MP: Muchas gracias.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)